right the jets ultimately were attracted
to robert sala he spoke yesterday on his
role as former defensive coordinator now
head coach will he be calling the
defensive plays or will he delegate that
that's among the things that saul spoke
about here he is
i'm not going to be handling play
calling duties on defense um got the
utmost respect and confidence in jeff
albrecht to be able to do that um
i'm i'm i share the same thoughts as
they do i i think the head coach and and
the messenger
is trying to be deployed to everybody
this is a an organization that has to
work locked in arms and work together
and uh and to ensure that the messaging
and the way we want things done all the
way across the board
is there and maintaining that connection
throughout whether it's offense defense
special teams business to
football somehow some way everyone's got
to find their connection to the player
and uh
to with the mindset that we're going to
get these guys better every single day
and
and to be able to have that focus and
ensure that the entire organization is
moving in the direction that we want
i i won't be calling plays
what a difference between campbell and
salah very
very reason very calm very resolute very
confident in a suit jacket and tie he'll
never wear again i i i wonder how much
he paid for that stuff he's never going
to wear again but anyway um i i kind of
i kind of i kind of i want to hear like
any time we're we're we show one of
these clips and at the end i i wish it
would still keep going
you got it you got a winner there that i
wish that clip would have kept going i
wanted to hear more from robert salah
yeah well
you know after i saw some of the solace
sound last night mike
uh one of the first thoughts i had was
i can imagine that uh in his interview
with the detroit lions now as most
people know robert salas from detroit
son of michigan
uh and
a lot of people in detroit and in the
detroit area desperately wanted robert
sala to be the head coach of the detroit
lions and i can just imagine in the
course of the interview process someone
asked him uh coach sala um
are you willing to
when you coach your players have them
bite off the opposing kneecaps
no i'm not willing to do that okay uh
coach thanks a lot we'll get back to you
yeah
but apparently you got no qualifications
he is a far more reasoned you know i
think over the years mike
you know when i remember the year on
monday night football when i think we
talked about this a couple of weeks ago
when uh the cameras on monday night
football found him 105 times and found
ken norton the uh defensive coordinator
of the seattle seahawks like 12 times in
the same game and it's because he's an
excitable guy on the sidelines robert
sala and he's sort of one of these guys
it's like he's a player out there looks
like a player you know uh emotes like a
player
but
richard sherman told me this earlier in
this year when i was saying what's salah
really like and he goes
he's really really thoughtful and when
he puts a game plan together and you
walk out of there you say that's a smart
game plan you know that that really is
putting us in the best position to win
and you know mike the best thing about
robert sala in my opinion was this
season
right away right out of the box he
basically has to go without bosa and
without sherman
for the majority of the year
and and some lesser lights as well
and he still put out a defense that was
highly competitive every single week i i
think that's a good hire for the jets
what a meteoric rise seven years ago
he's a quality control coach with the
seattle seahawks gets a super bowl ring
there jaguars for three years lands with
kyle shanahan in san francisco and now
here he is head coach of the jets but
but i i just i i was impressed with him
he can
maybe he should be the guy who tries to
bring back the old mike nolan and jack
del rio wear suits during a game thing
because uh he came off pretty well in
that suit and it just shows he can
compartmentalize his personality to suit
the situation sidelines he's ready to
rumble boardroom he's ready to talk in a
very recent voice and make his points in
a very compelling way so i think that
you know when you think about what the
new york teams have been through
recently when it comes to coaches and
these interviews and the failures of the
teams and we've got one playoff
appearance over the last eight years
from either of the teams the the the
miami boat trip game for the giants a
few years ago um i i i think that the
jets fans are going to be happy with
robert solo
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports